vor kurzem hat mir ein Zuschauer dieses
Bild hier zukommen lassen es zeigt ein
außerirdisches Flugobjekt davon bin ich
absolut überzeugt für mich ein
eindeutiger Beweis für Aliens denn was
soll es anderes sein was mich schockiert
hat ist dass da niemand darüber redet
die US-Regierung nicht unsere eigene
Regierung nicht nicht mal der NASA
können wir vertrauen und die haben die
Saturn 5 Rakete gebaut können wir jetzt
noch nicht mal mehr glauben dass wir auf
dem Mond waren wir müssen jetzt handeln
wir können uns auch niemand mehr
verlassen wir werden hier alleine
gelassen die Regierungen wollen dass wir
sterben und nämlich von den Aliens
ersetzt werden wir gegen die Aliens es
gibt niemand anderen mehr bitte hört mir
zu schnell
in the skies that we don't know exactly
what there Aliens das Internet ist voll
davon unzählige Blogs fuhren und leider
vor allem auch Youtube Videos wollen
einem ständig weiß machen dass sie
Beweise von echten UFOs oder
alien-sichtungen haben die Videos heißen
zum Beispiel Aliens haben uns besucht
das ändert alles oder sie sind überall
er ist kürzlich berichtete ich euch gar
über einen mysteriösen Fund ein
außerirdisches Wesen in einem Sarkophag
ganz oft sind diese Beweise dann Fotos
oder Videos der absolut miesesten
Qualität in denen man fremde Flugobjekte
oder andere Außerirdische Dinge sehen
sollen für mich ist das eine Ecke des
Internets von der ich mich fernhalte ich
halte das alles für absoluten Quatsch
wenn wir wirklich Außerirdische auf
unserer Erde entdeckt hätten dann würden
alle großen Regierungen und Behörden
dieser Welt das nicht geheim halten
können zumindest nicht unsere dann
würden viele Wissenschaftler
Untersuchungen anstellen und auch
seriöse Zeitungen würden darüber
berichten aber hier schau mal selbst die
Bilder darüber berichtet Quad erat
demonstrand okay aber das US-Militär hat
selbst gesagt dass sie UFOs gesichtet
haben die US-Regierung nimmt das Thema
mittlerweile sehr ernst ja das stimmt
das Militär hat echte UFOs gesichtet und
vor kurzem sogar futterstoffform
veröffentlicht kein Scherz aber es ist
nicht das ganz viele dachten
UFO heißt an identified flying object
aber nicht identifiziertes Flugobjekt
bedeutet eben nur dass sie nicht
identifizieren konnten was es ist und
nur weil man etwas nicht identifizieren
kann ist es noch lange kein Alien das
sagt auch Astronaut Chris Hatfield der
deutlich mehr Erfahrung mit Flugobjekten
hat als ich aber
icness things in the sky that on
understand
to see something in the sky that
you looking
live from another sOliver System ist
Rasiermesser oft auch das
wissenschaftliche sparsamkeitsprinzip
besagt dass die Theorie die mit der
geringsten Anzahl an Variablen und zu
beweisenden Hypothesen auskommt das
Phänomen sehr wahrscheinlich am besten
erklärt oder simpel ausgedrückt die
einfachste Erklärung ist immer die
wahrscheinlichste denn das hier
alles mögliche sein natürlich
vorkommende Phänomene im Himmel wie eine
Wolke in Kombination mit einer optischen
Täuschung oder einem Lichtreflex in der
Kamera das könnte ein Vogel sein oder
auch einfach nur Müll irgendein
Wetterballon der vom Wind mitgenommen
wurde gerne werden auch normale
Flugzeuge oder spionageflugzeuge gesehen
die dann durch Nebel oder ähnliches
unheimlich wirken oder
Inversionswetterlagen oder Sterne oder
man sieht Blitze hoch oben in den Wolken
und kann sie nicht richtig zuordnen
deswegen spricht man inzwischen auch
nicht mehr von UFOs sondern von UAP an
identified aerial vernommener und
vielleicht auch weil das Wort UFO
inzwischen quasi synonym mit Aliens ist
und man versucht von diesen Stick mal
wegzukommen
ich bin Jason der Alien und ich sage
euch glaubt nicht was euch der
menschling da erzählt wer Aliens wir
sind total echt oh ja wir leben hier auf
der Erde schon ganz lange aber im
Geheimen ihr seht uns zwar manchmal und
habt ihr eine gute Kamera dabei um uns
zu fotografieren
[Gelächter]
deswegen können wir ganz entspannt eure
linken Socken klauen eure Politik in
frittieren und uns in eure Geräte hacken
oh ja das macht besonders Spaß und zwar
mit man in the middle attacks da tun wir
so als wenn wir z.B ein offenes WLAN mit
dem ihr euch dann connecten können nun
ist das gar kein WLAN und ihr connectet
euch in Wahrheit mit unseren Geräten
damit wir eure Daten ausspionieren
können
das klappt nur leider nicht wenn eure
Daten verschlüsselt sind das sieht man
an dem https und dem kleinen Schloss
oben in der URL zeile oder natürlich ihr
nutzt nordvpn denn dann sind alle eure
Daten dauerhaft verschlüsselt und die
haben gar keine Chance menno nordvpn
kostet nur 2,88 € pro Monat ja
tatsächlich auch für uns Aliens es gibt
eine 30 Tage Geld zurück Garantie und
wenn ihr ein zwei Jahresabo bucht dann
kriegt ihr vier ganze Monate geschenkt
krass solche guten Angebote gibt's nicht
mehr auf meinem Heimatplaneten
so und jetzt lasst euch ruhig von dem
menschlichen weiter erzählen dass es gar
keine Aliens gibt
[Gelächter]
ihr fragt euch jetzt vielleicht warum
sind denn diese Fotos und Videos alle
immer so super verschwommen oder wurden
durch einen Nachtsichtgerät aufgenommen
oder von einer kartoffelkamera wieso
kann man nicht einmal ein vernünftiges
gutes HD Foto mit einer aktuellen Kamera
machen inzwischen hat doch jeder ein
Smartphone mit einer 4k Kamera oder
vielleicht weil die Aliens immer nur
dann auftauchen wenn Sie sehen dass
jemand eine sehr schlechte Kamera dabei
hat nein ganz einfach wenn die Fotos
oder Videos besser wären würde man sehen
dass es keine Aliens sind orkhams
Rasiermesser zum Beispiel dieses Video
hier das haben viele Leute jahrelang als
Beweis für Aliens gesehen weil dieses
Raumschiff hier dreieckig ist aha
dreieckige Flugzeuge gibt es gar nicht
das müssen Aliens sein dann hat sich
aber ein paar Jahre später
herausgestellt die Kombination aus einer
SLR-Kamera und dem Nachtsichtgerät durch
das aufgenommen wurde sorgt dafür dass
das Licht dreieckig erscheint und das
Flugobjekt selber war einfach nur eine
Drohne wenn wir nicht alle Daten haben
fängt unser Gehirn an auf eigene Faust
nach Lösungen zu suchen und Verbindungen
zu knüpfen und das ist eigentlich gut
aber wenn man das Gesehene nicht
natürlich erklären kann dann bleiben
einem eben nur die Aliens oder Bigfoot
oder noch Ness was meint ihr warum
sollte unerklärlichen Phänomene immer
weit weg von der Zivilisation passieren
mitten in der Wüste oder auf hoher See
bei Nacht oder im Wald weil man da lange
Zeit alleine ist und das Gehirn schnell
anfängt irgendwo Zusammenhänge zu sehen
und ich mache den Menschen da nicht mal
ein Vorwurf jeder der schon mal alleine
nachts durch den Wald gegangen ist weiß
wie schnell man hinter jedem Baum
slenderman oder einen Mörder erwartet
oder shiale Bar ich bezweifle gar nicht
dass die Menschen wirklich glauben was
sie da gesehen haben und im Zweifel
haben sie sogar irgendetwas gesehen aber
eben nicht Aliens sondern natürliche
Phänomene die man sich eben in der
Situation nicht erklären kann manchmal
sind diese Videos aber übrigens gar
keine Phänomene im Himmel sondern
Fälschungen wie vfx-künstler immer
wieder zeigen
Fall da bitte nicht drauf rein ich weiß
nicht wer Spaß an sowas hat aber
anscheinend nutzen einige ihr Talent am
Computer um andere Menschen im Internet
zu verarschen okay gut ich will mich
hier natürlich nicht nur über Alien
Youtube Kanäle lustig machen also ab
jetzt nicht mehr stell mich ja immer
gerne auf die Seite der Wissenschaft und
will natürlich auch offen für andere
Blickwinkel sein also was sagt die
Wissenschaft zu Aliens gibt es sie nun
die meisten Wissenschaftler denken ja es
gibt Aliens also ich gehe davon aus dass
relativ viele Astronomen davon ausgehen
dass es Leben außerhalb des
Sonnensystems gibt die Bestimmung der
Zahl der Intelligenzen im in unserer
Milchstraße ist nicht so ganz einfach
zuerst wurde das von Drake Widder direkt
Gleichung gemacht die also versucht aus
bekannten und spekulativen Faktoren eine
Abschätzung zu erzeugen wie viele
Zivilisationen gibt es in der
Milchstraße oder meinetwegen auch sogar
im ganzen Universum die Rechnung die sie
hier angestellt haben ist die sogenannte
Drake-Gleichung hierfür multipliziert
man mehrere Faktoren miteinander und
herauskommt wie wieder außerirdische
Zivilisationen es gerade vermutlich gibt
der Trick ist nur die richtigen Werte zu
nehmen und das ist teilweise extrem
spekulativ wie lange zum Beispiel glaubt
ihr dass eine Alien Zivilisation im
Durchschnitt überlebt tausend Jahre
100.000 sowas kann man einfach nicht
seriös berechnen aber selbst wenn man
gemäßigte Schätzungen macht kommt eine
Quelle schon auf 56 andere intelligente
Alien Zivilisationen die jetzt gerade
allein in unserer Galaxie Leben und da
sind die anderen schätzungsweise 100
Milliarden Galaxien in unserem Universum
noch gar nicht mit eingerechnet trotzdem
man muss sagen Hinweise auf
außerirdisches Leben haben wir noch nie
gefunden aber gut spielen wir mal einen
Gedankenexperiment durch lasst uns die
Perspektive umdrehen und sagen dass wir
jetzt die Aliens sind genauso wie auf
der Erde wo wir in fast allen Ländern
Ausländer sind sind wir ja auch auf
allen anderen Planeten Aliens also wir
sind in einigen hundert Jahren
technologisch so weit fortgeschritten
dass unser Sonnensystem verlassen und zu
anderen Sternen fliegen können wir
überleben eine jahrhundertelange Reise
und kommen endlich am Ziel an einem
anderen Planeten mit leben wenn wir sie
zerstören wollten dann könnten wir das
vermutlich mit einem Knopfdruck machen
und wenn wir Sie kennenlernen wollen
dann würden wir versuchen vielleicht
über das elektromagnetische Spektrum
Kontakt aufzunehmen und hätten uns
eventuell auch schon vorher angekündigt
so oder so der Planet hätte es
mitbekommen es gibt nur einen Grund
warum wir unentdeckt bleiben wollten um
diese andere Spezies zu beobachten ohne
sie zu stören genauso wie wir auch hier
auf der Erde Ureinwohner die seit
Jahrhunderten keinen Kontakt zur
Außenwelt hatten in Ruhe lassen
aber wenn wir wirklich technologisch so
advanced sind dass wir Generationen
Schiffe bauen können glaubt ihr dann
wirklich dass wir uns von ein zwei
Hobbyfotografen fotografieren lassen
oder wir lassen uns vom Militär mit
Radarsensoren tracken führen dann
Manöver durch die sie mit ihrer
Technologie nicht durchführen können und
hauen dann wieder ab haha das wird Ihnen
den Kopf zermattern ja ausschließen kann
man das natürlich nicht das ist eine
Möglichkeit von vielen und etwas
auszuschließen weil es unwahrscheinlich
ist wäre natürlich auch Quatsch aber
gibt es denn irgendwelche Hinweise auch
nur den allerkleinsten auf Aliens in
diesem Videos ganz klares NEIN es gibt
keinerlei Hinweise darauf seriöse
Hinweise darauf dass das extra
terrestrisches Leben ist oder so etwas
auch wenn es für einige Phänomene noch
keine Erklärung gibt sollte man das
nicht sofort als Beweis für Aliens sehen
was andere Youtube Kanäle hier aber
regelmäßig tun es ist fast so als würde
sich dieses Video Thema einfach nur sehr
Gut klicken und man versucht künstlich
immer wieder neue Phänomene und
schlechte Kameraaufnahmen das beweise
für Alien zu verkaufen um damit Geld zu
machen
okay was ist das Fazit solange es
schlechte Kameraaufnahmen oder auch nur
Augenzeugen Berichte gibt wird es
Menschen geben die darin Zeichen für
Aliens sehen und zwar weil sie das
unbedingt wollen bei allen anderen
Videos von Flugzeugen oder
lichtspektakeln in denen man klar
erkennen kann was gefilmt wird mit ja
auch nicht gesagt dass das Aliens sind
nur wenn genug Daten fehlen um zu
zweifeln dann kommen die YouTube-Videos
mit der mysteriösen Hintergrundmusik
ja es macht Spaß darüber nachzudenken
und zu diskutieren Aliens sind direkt am
Übergang von Wissenschaft zu Science
Fiction und wir machen ja auch gerne
Videos darüber wie zum Beispiel der
erste Kontakt mit Außerirdischen
aussehen würde oder wie man mit ihnen
kommunizieren könnte aber bitte lasst
euch von ein paar verwackelten Videos
nicht den Kopf verdrehen wie immer
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig euer Patrick